norman voulais me défie au ping pong ou
pas parce que j'ai eu très chaud là je
suis libre à connaître pas chaud à moins
que le public me motive
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
maintenant vu des voitures
c'est mon voeu
à la normale
avant le tuto de matthieu delormeau
normal si vous gagnez en deux points
si vous gagnez vous êtes obligé de faire
une vidéo expressément sur touche pas à
mon poste c'est bien une vidéo que pour
nous c'est que les vidéos de norman
c'est la folie quoi ça sera un cadeau de
fou pour nous en revanche si vous gagnez
je ferai une spéciale norman même sans
vous d'accord on rails émissions
spéciales normales
je veillerai ok on valide ses prêts en
deux tons beige et une petite pompe
ok allez attention c'est pas bon on
considère qu on va la faire en trois
points on commence un match maintenant
aller avoue de servir alors fait match
aller j'avais déjà des idées sur la
vidéo c'est en train de se créer allez
mais non attention gardez dernier tout
seul c'est la balle de match vraiment
nul à chier je suis vraiment un bel
arrêt vous tous joué sur l'étape plus
grande d'habitude
sur cette page vous libère le coeur
à
[Applaudissements]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
non
nonoban
[Musique]